My name is Lee Dyer.
I've been teaching human
resource management
at Cornell University
for 45 years.
I've seen a lot of
change in that time,
but none more profound or more
important than the changes that
lie ahead.
Over the next few years
major transformations
will be taking place
in the nature of work.
And it will be up to each of us
to decide how these will unfold
and to make sure that they work
out the way we want them to be.
As this figure shows,
HR professionals
will be right square in
the middle of things.
Ultimately it is the
human resource strategies
that organizations enact
which play a major role
in determining how
many jobs are created,
as well as the
quality of these jobs.
But of course, HR professionals
don't operate in a vacuum.
The number of forces,
global competition,
the emerging technological
developments,
societal pressures, and
labor market conditions
influence firms'
business strategies,
and in turn, their human
resource strategies.
And there are a number of key
players in the process as well.
These include labor
organizations of various types,
public policy makers
who make and enforce
the rules of the
game, and educators
who are responsible for helping
folks develop the skills they
need to succeed.
The challenge for
HR professionals
is to understand the
environmental forces at work
and to work with the key players
to develop desired results.
And of course, this
means doing all
they can to be sure that
their organizations have
enough high quality people to
do the work that needs doing.
But it also means
striving to ensure
that everyone who wants to
work is able to get a job.
And not just any job.
But one that provides both
a decent standard of living
and a sense of personal
fulfillment and accomplishment.
This is where our
course comes in.
You will learn how the
important external forces--
globalization,
technology, and so forth--
have changed over time and are
expected to change in the years
ahead.
You also will learn
what can be expected
of key players in the process--
labor organizations, public
policy makers, and so forth--
in the coming years,
and how you can
work with them to forge
mutually acceptable agreements
on key issues.
In short, if you are or
are aspiring to be an HR
professional or a manager,
completion of this course
will help position
you to influence
the nature of the changes
that will be taking
place in the years ahead, both
in the US and around the world.